- So is it true that you
recently said that Chris
is who you wanna be when you grow up?
(Kelly laughs)
- I didn't say it in front of him.
You're embarrassing me now.
(Kelly laughs)
Yeah, man.
Chris is a great guy
with a real integrity,
and he's brilliant, and he's a great dad,
and he's just a...
And also, he knows everybody.
(Men laugh)
Like, I'm not even kidding.
You can bring up a name.
It doesn't matter if
it's like, Muhammad Ali,
Paul McCartney, Jesus, you know.
(Kelly and audience laughs)
Chris is like, "yeah, that's my boy!"
I'm like, what do you
mean that's your boy?
How do you know?
Like, not only do you know Michael Jordan.
I was like, there's this guy,
Howard White, who works at...
He goes, "I know Howard
White, he's my friend!"
I'm like, this is unbelievable...
- Oh my gosh, so you're his guy.
- [Man] I still have not found
anyone that you don't know.
- You know everybody?
- I kinda do, you know?
(everyone laughs)
I mean, Ben and my buddy, Dave Chappelle,
they always joke like,
"you know everybody man!
You everywhere! Where are you right now?"
I'm like, "I'm in Saudi
Arabia with the king."
(audience laughs)
I'll call you right back,
he's giving gifts away.
- He's giving gifts away.
It's his Oprah's Favorite
Things, that's amazing.
Okay, how about like Stevie
Wonder? You know Stevie Wonder?
- I know Stevie. Stevie's,
oh man, he called me.
- Keep trying.
You're gonna have to go way
deeper than Stevie Wonder.
- I thought it was gonna be cool,
'cause he handed me my first Grammy.
So I was gonna be like, "my
story's pretty good, Chris."
I was like, no, but you
know Stevie, that's so cool.
- I was like, you know Muhammad Ali is...
He was like, yeah, "I met
Muhammad. I know Muhammad."
- Muhammad Ali
- Muhammad Ali?
- He said, "you a funny mother Tucker."
I said, "oh hey!"
(audience laughs)
(Kelly claps)
I thought he was gonna say something else.
Like some wisdom, you know.
- I'm like, that's the
highest, you know, right there.
- You a funny mother Tucker.
- You should retire! That's
as good as it's gonna get.
- I know. Met Mandela. Met Mandela.
- Oh my gosh!
- Went to Africa and he was
like, "where is Chris Tucker?"
(audience laughs)
"I want him to meet my grandkids."
I was like, "did Mandela
just say my name?"
- [Kelly] That's incredible.
- B.B. King, B.B. King.
- [Kelly] Oh my gosh.
My, he was like, "Hey Chris".
Bill Russell. People like that.
I mean, it's, it's great to,
you know, just, just meet them.
- [Kelly] That's incredible.
- Yeah.
- Now you know why I
wanna be Chris Tucker.
(everyone laughs)
- Are you the person
that can really remember?
Like, I was a waitress, so
I feel like I'm really good
with faces, but names I'm
always like, "interesting".
- Yes, with faces but not names. Yeah.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- You used the right,
you must be left-handed.
You use the right side of your brain.
- No, I'm, no, I'm right-handed.
- Oh, okay.
But like, I have horrible handwriting,
so it doesn't matter which hand I'm using.
- Me too, me too.
- Yes. But no, I, I literally,
I can remember faces well.
But names I'm always like, "you...".
- Oh yeah. Yeah. Men use the faces.
- You do the like, "nice to see ya".
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Especially if it's out of context. Yes.